thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air almost 2 million
Facebook users have pledged to storm
area 51 to demand answers about UFOs the
planned event is scheduled for September
20th 2019 we're through the
looking-glass people the truth is out
there the US Air Force is used area 51
for nuclear testing experimental
aircraft and defense systems but for
decades people have suspected that area
51 houses dead aliens spaceships and
other gear related to alien life
although the Facebook user who organized
the event has said the whole thing is a
joke
plenty of people are taking this post
seriously in just 1% of people who
signed up online decided to actually
show up the government could have a big
problem on its hands and the truth could
finally be revealed that's why the Air
Force actually issued a statement area
51 is an open training range for the US
Air Force and we would discourage anyone
from trying to come into the area where
we trained American Armed Forces
the Air Force is ready to protect
America and its assets
what started as a joke is evolving into
a serious attempt to learn more about
one of the government's most notorious
military black sites so what would
happen if people actually tried to
invade area 51 well we're about to find
out
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer and today we are talking about
the legal ramifications of what would
happen of a bunch of idiots stormed area
51
so what is area 51 area 51 is the common
name of a highly classified US Air Force
facility located within the Nevada test
and training range the US government
setup area 51 after World War 2 when it
was developing the u-2 spy plane area 51
is near a dry lakebed called groom lake
about 90 miles north of Las Vegas the
first YouTube planes took flight in 1955
and immediately reports poured in about
unidentified flying objects or UFOs the
u-2 spy plane was so advanced it
appeared alien even to commercial pilots
since the US Air Force was not going to
acknowledge the existence of its
super-secret spy plane program the
government dismissed UFO sightings as
natural phenomena or weather events
which has spawned decades of conspiracy
theories ever since even after the
YouTube program stopped testing at the
site
the Air Force continued to use area 51
we just don't know everything that they
have used it for the theories about
aliens intensified in 1989 when an
engineer named Bob Lazar told the local
Las Vegas news that he had worked on
alien technology at area 51 yeah I
didn't even believe in flying saucers up
until I was employed at s4
he claimed to have seen nine different
kinds of UFOs during his work at area 51
the Air Force of course did not comment
on Bob Lazar in fact for years the
government has refused to even confirm
area 51's existence despite the many
credible accounts that real people were
actually working at the site the
government is doing everything but
looking out for us I mean the only thing
they're looking at is for themselves for
example in the 1990s lawyer Jonathan
Turley represented federal workers from
area 51 who had been exposed to some
kind of burning chemical that had caused
catastrophic health problems doctors
could not even identify what chemicals
could have caused the damage although
the government did finally acknowledge
the site President Clinton issued a
blanket waiver letting area51 keep its
chemicals secret interest in area 51
peaked again
in 2019 after Lazar went on Joe Rogan's
podcast to describe his alleged role in
attempting to reverse-engineer alien
technology at area 51 Lazar is a
self-proclaimed physicist who claims to
have worked at a facility called s4
inside of a mountain I went into the
hangar door and in the hangar door was
the disk the flying saucer that I worked
on this was a small reactor about the
size of a hemisphere about the size of a
basketball on a metal plate and when it
was running it produced a gravitational
field a gravitational field of it so
regardless of whether Lazar is credible
it is undeniable that things are still
happening at area 51 a secret commuter
jet known as Janet airline still
transports federal workers from the Las
Vegas Airport to the site it's actually
the only way that federal workers can
get in and the site is actually
expanding according to a popular
mechanics aerial time-lapse a new runway
was built buildings have been added and
the government is still excavating the
mountainside so the question is could
people storm area 51 well there are two
big problems with storming area 51 the
first is practical and the second is
legal the practical problem with stormy
area 51 is how to get close enough to
the site to actually do or see something
I'm not gonna go into too much detail
about all of the practical problems of
storming area 51
because real-life lore has already done
an amazing video essay about all of the
practical issues including a lot of
information about Janet Airlines and the
issues of storming an airbase in the
middle of the Nevada desert so
definitely go check out that video after
you watch this one link in the
doobly-doo but suffice to say the
closest town to area 51 is Rachel Nevada
population of 58 conspiracy theorists
routinely gather there for conventions
and fun and the locals play along with
souvenir shops alien themed food and
general kitsch the only hotel in town is
the little alien which is already booked
for September 19th and 20th so obviously
someone intends to show up and they've
already booked their rooms Rachel is
located on Nevada Highway 375 which is
sometimes called the Extra Terrestrial
highway to get close to area 51 people
must take a dirt road from route 375
which leads to restricted lands
you can get about 15 miles up the dirt
road before you start seeing fences and
security now area 51 is a classified
military operating area that means that
not all of the borders of the huge area
are fenced or walled however they are
marked by orange posts and plenty of
warning signs the signs prohibit
photographs and trespass those who have
approached the borders have been
confronted by men wearing camouflage it
isn't clear whether these camouflage men
are military personnel or private
security but area 51 enthusiasts have
dubbed the men camo dudes youtuber
adventures with Kristian has made
several trips to area 51 including
hiking nearby mountain ranges and
driving to various perimeter points
Kristian once drove up to the back gate
which is guarded by a high fence several
buildings and the camo dudes the armed
guards followed Kristian as he drove
back on another occasion Kristian tried
to sleep inside his vehicle near a
different gate but he was met by police
and again camouflaged military personnel
the police politely told Christian to
leave Christian's experience seems to
confirm some of the rules of engagement
for area 51 security personnel they are
reportedly ordered to observe and act as
a deterrent rather than seeking direct
engagement with press passers however
they will contact local law enforcement
to deal with anyone who is suspicious
the military uses motion sensors cameras
and other early warning devices to
notify them every time someone
approaches area 51 that's why the best
way to see the restricted area might be
from the air however it's illegal to fly
over area 51's airspace the airspace
above area 51 is a 23 mile by 25 mile
no-fly zone so don't expect that you'll
be able to fly any drones nearby even
pilots from local air force bases in
California and Nevada are prohibited
from flying over area 51 without
permission pilots who have attempted to
fly into one of the buffer zones around
the airspace are punished even if it's
just a mistake and pilots caught
knowingly flying into area 51 airspace
can be court-martialed drones are also a
no-go when Hans Faulkner used a drone to
take several videos of area 51 from
above the military quickly posted new
signs explicitly prohibiting the use of
drones but let's say you managed to turn
down route 375 and approach the
boundaries will law enforcement be there
to stop you this
brings us to the second issue with
storming area 51 the legal problem and
oh boy there are lots of legal problems
trespassing on military bases is a crime
under Title 18 section 1382 no person
may enter a military installation
without permission military
installations include a quote military
naval or Coast Guard reservation post
fort Arsenal yard stationed or
installation area 51 is considered part
of Edwards Air Force Base so it
qualifies as a place you cannot enter
without serious consequences those found
guilty of trespass face six months in
federal prison a $500 fine or both and
the authorities take this issue very
seriously no kidding
in 2014 a tour bus accidentally drove
past the warning signs and got just
inside of area 51 military personnel
armed with assault rifles pulled the bus
over and threatened to arrest the
passengers and their guide they were
charged with misdemeanor trespass and
given six hundred and fifty dollar fines
in 2016 a BBC show called conspiracy
road trip decided to film the perimeter
very 51 they approached the security Hut
but when no-one came out the crew 12
decided to keep going past the security
Hut and see how far they could get
to me it seemed like an ordinary
military facility but my companions were
convinced this was the gateway to the
Extra Terrestrial secrets
the guards were inside watching a
basketball game when one of the camera
crew knocked on the window of the
security Hut armed guards rushed out and
held the men at gunpoint they were
forced to lie on the ground for three
hours while the FBI ran security checks
to would-be alien hunters and those who
believed Fox Mulder's claim that the
truth is out there no government agency
has jurisdiction over the truth these
penalties may seem not so bad it
actually gets much much worse the
perimeter of area 51 contains no
trespass signs warning people that the
military can use deadly force has the
military ever used deadly force against
a trespasser yes yes they have earlier
this year area 51 security personnel
shot and killed a man who approached the
perimeter in a car and blew past
security checkpoints after an 8 mile car
chase he jumped out of the car and when
the man held a quote cylindrical object
in his hands guards shot him dead on the
spot
in addition to death which is probably
bad enough people rounded up after an
attack on area 51 could be charged with
acts of terrorism the Patriot Act
defines domestic terrorism as an attempt
to quote intimidate or coerce a civilian
population to influence the policy of a
government by intimidation or coercion
or to affect the conduct of a government
by mass destruction assassination or
kidnapping although there is no separate
federal offense for domestic terrorism
defendants could be charged under
specific state and federal laws for
example it is illegal to kill or attempt
to kill a federal agent or to use
explosives to destroy a federal building
these kinds of charges carry serious
prison time
even if thousands of alien enthusiasts
showed up on September 20th it looks
like the US military would probably be
ready to respond
remember that area 51 is inside the
Nevada test and training range where the
military conducts live target practice
and conducts simulated war I was curious
about this myself so I spoke to a friend
who was a major in the Marines serving
as an artillery officer joint terminal
attack controller and a military
prosecutor for the Judge Advocate
General I asked him what would happen if
thousands of civilians stormed area 51
and where they would be tried his
respond
was they wouldn't be tried anywhere
because they'd be dead so there's that
good night everyone but when I pressed
him he said that supposing they actually
survived they'd be tried in the local
federal district court which would be
the federal court in the District of
Nevada but he also pointed out that the
military is not in a habit of fighting
back in the media so they would be
especially reluctant to use lethal force
against a huge group of people in a
highly publicized event
now given the forewarning to the US
military the Air Force is likely
building up a supply of non-lethal force
an actual invasion would be met with
multiple levels of non-lethal force in
ascending levels of brutality so long as
the buildings and hangars were secure
the Air Force would be unlikely to use
more than really really painful less
than lethal force so what's the verdict
could people storm area51 and make
something happen
probably but what would actually happen
would be mass arrests and even death if
people got particularly aggressive of
course this doesn't mean that there
aren't questions about area 51 that are
worth asking
it's just unlikely that massing outside
the entrance to an Air Force Base will
yield any real answers what has worked
well a good old-fashioned Freedom of
Information Act or FOIA request back in
2005 Jeffrey T rich Olson as senior
fellow at the National Security Archive
submitted a FOIA request about area 51
eight years later the CIA sent back the
largest cache of documents about area 51
ever released and confirming the site's
existence for the very first time and
confirming once again that the lawyers
are the real American heroes
now obviously aliens have never come to
Planet Earth but it's only a matter of
time until they do now if you want to
prepare for an alien invasion I'd
recommend World War a aliens invade
earth on curiosity stream World War a is
a great documentary where leading
scientists and researchers weigh in on
the scenarios that might actually unfold
if aliens did find us and decide to
visit earth it's a great bit of
speculative nonfiction and it asks
should we even be searching for
extraterrestrial life and what are the
risks of reaching out and
are the risks if Earth is found by
aliens
curiosity stream is the home of over
24,000 shows and documentaries about
science nature history technology
society and lifestyle legal eagles get a
free account for 30 days by clicking the
link below or by using the promo code
legal eagle using the promo code really
helps out this channel so click on the
link below and learn how you can fight
back against the coming extraterrestrial
invasion so do you agree leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real law reviews over here
where I will see you in court